eli gold has been calling all the action
for alabama football
for 32 years now and he hosts the nick
saban show one hour program
airing every thursday night during the
regular season and the postseason eli
kind enough
to join us how was uh the show with
coach last night eli
it was fine dan and it's great to be on
with you and uh
yeah he was of course what he did do was
obviously work from home it was a zoom
set up very much like
you and i have here this morning but yes
normally he's there with us but
he was on zoom and he was he was
wonderful
he felt great he was smiling and again
what people see of nick saban sometimes
is that 40 second sound bite behind the
the podium during his press conference
on our talk show though
he's a whole lot looser the smiles are a
whole lot more free to flow and that's
how he was last night
he was just fine we were joined by andy
staples from the athletic
and that we all talked to bama football
and
we probably spent seven minutes of the
hour
talking about his medical condition and
he made it clear that he's doing just
fine
how is he planning on being involved in
this game like what what
we're trying to figure this out you know
eli how can he be involved
i i guess he's trying to figure it out
as well dan
he did take a few minutes of of his air
time to talk about how he wished
there was a better way to do this
uh you know could they not
alter rules not for him but for all
coaches
you know if if there is a situation like
this can you not work
from a a an isolated press box
area luxury suite whatever uh so i
honestly don't know any more
than you do um you know i it was clear
that
he was not relishing the idea of having
to be at the house
and i'm sure miss terry wasn't relishing
that idea either
having having the coach around the house
during a ball game but
as of last night and as of this morning
you know i have heard nothing
to indicate that he will be at the game
but
you just never know i would love to have
a camera on him eli
i would rather watch him watch the game
than watch the game itself
i hear yeah i don't i you know i'll tell
you i'll be very honest with you
uh after he and and greg byrne our
director of athletics uh
tested positive my family
got on me to go get a cove test
which i did yesterday morning and thank
god it was negative
but i said to my wife i said you know i
have not missed obama game
in 32 years i said i
cannot imagine having to sit around the
house
if i couldn't do the broadcast from the
house somehow i said i can't imagine
and i said i just can't imagine what
what coach saban would be going through
so uh you know we chuckle about it but
you know it could be reality but you
know what
everything that the man does and i know
you've visited with him many times
everything the man does is calculated
any potential opportunity
to educate and help the coaches get
ready for a game without him
has been done yesterday is being done
today
and will be done tomorrow up until 90
minutes before
kickoff so is it ideal no
you're never better without the greatest
coach
who is a hands-on coach walking the
sidelines
but if if god forbid he has to be at the
house
well it's not like he's got chopped
liver there on the sidelines he's got
some
some pretty good assistants who who will
run the show
your greatest call in your 32 years is
what
wow well i guess it's not for me to say
but your favorite your favorite call
there were two one because of the
context
and that was the overtime win against
georgia
for the national championship when two
uh uh through the uh
the second and 26 pass to devonta
smith the other one was at the rose bowl
stadium it wasn't the rose bowl game but
it was the rose bowl stadium
when bama beat texas for the national
championship
and for folks who don't remember and
very quickly back in the day
southern football was not what it is
today the west coast
teams were the powerhouses and alabama
got on the train and went out to
pasadena
and won two foosball games back in the
20s and
and and really elevated southern college
football
so bama was playing texas at the rose
bowl and the tide one that was the game
when colt mccoy
got hurt and i wrapped up the broadcast
by saying that the roses in this grand
old stadium
are once again crimson and that
kind of put a bow not only on the day
but on the history as bama goes back to
the rose bowl stadium
and and further asserts them so
i i was pretty proud of that one well
have fun this weekend should be a great
game obviously with uh
georgia and eli uh congrats on uh long
long success there well done 32 years
thank you for joining us
i tell people i started when i was three
nobody wants to believe
that but dan thanks it's great to be on
with you i i've loved your work for
years
thank you thank you eli that's the uh
play-by-play voice for alabama football
and as fritzi likes to point out
of course a guy from brooklyn who's
doing alabama football for 32. how
awesome is that